at the end of the day there is a ticker
tape running inside your chest that says
Eric is
worthless true or
false true that's the soil this nonsense
has grown out
of and until you address that core lie
cuz you're
not till you stop holding surviving
childhood versions of
yourself until you can forgive 20
6-year-old Eric for lying about a thing
that was really important or not telling
your parents the whole truth until you
can let 31-year-old Eric be a grown man
with his own
family until you get
there deal with that core I'm not
worthless man I'm actually a pretty good
guy that's hung in there your body's
going to continue to try to get your
attention